now to our coverage of the coronavirus
the centers for disease control is now
encouraging more of us to wear those n95
masks it's a new recommendation as cases
of the highly transmissible omicron
variant continue to add up hector mejia
joining us live this morning from the
newsroom hector you sat down you talked
to some local health experts about some
of this new guidance for us that's
correct good morning to you guys and
here is the concern we are seeing more
daily cases than the same time last year
clark county's positivity rate climbed
to 35.9
percent compare that to 21.5 percent
last year the southern nevada health
district says holiday gatherings and
travel likely led to the surge it could
take several more weeks before it starts
to taper down now because of the omicron
variant being more transmissible than
previous variants the cdc is now
recommending the use of n95 masks
the problem with the n95s and the can 95
masks is that they may be hard for
people to get
and even if people have access to them
they may not be
very comfortable the surgical mask alone
or a combination with a cloth mask over
the top of the surgical mask are some
alternatives if you are not able to find
an n95 that's according to the health
district now last week the biden
administration announced it's currently
working out a process to provide high
quality masks for free now we also
talked with the health district about
how long can you wear an n95 mask
outside of a medical setting before you
have to throw it away we'll talk about
that still ahead in the next half hour
reporting live hector mejia live local
now